hey everybody welcome back to park
attacks today it's time for Sakura
Gardens now the mission statement is as
follows attract more visitors to this
peaceful garden by adding amusement
rides and shops who are retaining its
old charm be careful of building
thrilling rides however as the guests
visiting the garden prefer gentle calmer
rights now the goals are to have at
least 500 guests in the park with a
cleanliness rating of 80% which isn't
too difficult
the only challenge that I kind of see is
the fact that we need to keep everything
quite gentle but as far as I've heard
from this scenario the rules on that are
pretty links as well so I think I can
build some decently medium intense
rollercoasters as well anyway it's
something we'll see I've actually kind
of been dreading doing this scenario
because I know this one is gonna be very
scenery focused and I'm not sure if I'm
gonna be able to pull it off that well
huge shout out to studio kV who I've
already of course done so many shoutouts
to so I don't think anybody who's
watching this video right now it doesn't
even know who kV is but in case you
don't he does amazing Park tech videos
and made a really good map for this
scenario in particular it's one that I
remember particularly for some reason I
just think it's really beautiful and I'm
gonna try and somehow make my map
hopefully even hold a candle to what he
did anyway
this is what the map looks like a simple
Japanese garden I actually made this
when Gabi made the sakura tree which is
the one that you can see here and I
thought it was so good that I just
wanted to build a scenario just the kind
of show of this tree at least that's how
I remember it being now most of the map
is quite empty but it does follow the
overall layout of a traditional Japanese
garden the kind that is built around the
lake so we have the central lake a
bridge and some other elements
interacting with it
a small pavilion down by the lake so
relaxing and then also a section with a
quite signature red bridge here which
you often see in Japanese Garner's as
well it's kind of based on this bridge
in a particular garden and next to Tokyo
Dome City it's just really pretty to
have this kind of hill set up with a red
Brij with a fake river running
underneath it I figured so that's the
reason for adding all of that but
despite following the general layout
over the Japanese go on in the park is
mostly empty and there's a lot of space
to work with too much even I'd reckon so
I'm gonna try to close some of these
paths off before I get started the rides
I guess are decent you could definitely
tell that the rides are geared toward a
lower intensity so that shouldn't be too
difficult but I'm still gonna research
thrill rides because I think most of
those should be fine and the same
honestly goes for coasters I mean at the
end of the day everything just kind of
depends on what the layouts you build is
going to be like and with that said
let's get started building that's a
beautiful sentence let's get started
with building and see where we end up
all right so for starters I went ahead
and removed the path at the entrance
because I have some different plans for
this area they're not actually that big
plans but I think everything is just
gonna work out much better if this whole
area is just going to be a very wide
path to lead into the rest of the
gardens I will have some more winding
paths going through the gardens as
you'll typically see in Japanese gardens
but I think for the context of the theme
park and they sort of quote unquote Main
streets that I want to build I wanted to
have this very wide open area at the
beginning here now this is where we
enter some coaster building already
which is kind of exciting I think but
you're gonna have to keep in mind that
I'm gonna spend most of this episode
again on buildings especially since
we're doing some Japanese stuff it's
gonna be quite detailed and very
detailed the focused in general but I
wanted to get this roller coaster out of
the way because I'm gonna need to build
something even slightly thrilling
because the choice of rice that we start
out with is not that great and I
definitely need something to rake in the
money so hopefully if all goes well this
coaster is gonna be my main tickets to
making a profit at some point in the
future but that said I'm also not sure
because all of the crazy Japanese
architecture plans that I have don't
really fare too well in a gameplay
perspective because they're very
expensive but yeah I really hope that
this coast is gonna be able to offset
that other than that it's just the
simple
family coaster with lots of curves and
little dips and valleys and a final
helix and then it's back into the
station nothing too spectacular but
again I'm trying my best to have some
sort of variety in these layouts while
also keeping them very true to what
they're like in real life and at the
same time this one is slightly more
interesting because it does follow the
terrain so at least it's not the kind of
coaster that you can just randomly plop
down everywhere now the station building
for this is going to be quite
extravagant I was inspired to just build
a large Japanese temple it isn't
actually based on anything in particular
honestly I've done so many Japanese
builds in planet coaster and planet Zoo
and park sector at this point that I
just have this folder of my computer
with all kinds of references for
Japanese architecture things to be
inspired by or things to like see the
rules and conventions basically it's
something that's like baked into my head
at this point so even though I usually
you know like to get a lot of references
and search on the internet for
inspiration or ideas on certain themes
when it comes to Japanese at this point
I just referred back to my old folder
and I'm just like all right what kind of
stuff can we do nowadays so actually
when I was doing this build I wasn't
really looking for Japanese architecture
in specific specifically to base it on
but rather trying to figure out ways in
which you could build it in park attacks
because personally for me my struggle is
not really you know seeing what Japanese
architecture is like because at this
point I have so much real-life
experience and knowledge about it that
it's not really the struggle the real
struggle is trying to shoehorn these
grid conforming pieces in park attacks
into a Japanese theme and somehow turn
it into a detailed building so I went
actually back and looked at what other
people did who tackled the Japanese
theme before now this would probably be
most notably myself on pagoda valley
both the scenario itself and me trying
to make it but also studio kV has done
some really great Asian builds and I
think he did a really good
Sakura gardens as well that was quite
inspiring but then I'm not really going
to base anything off of but what I did
look into is a specific user of the park
attack discord by the name of Pierre
Jean oh I think it is who's really
talented and actually an artist in real
life and who built this Japanese Dogu
coaster with the station that I thought
was super interesting because they use
this technique of using the very flat
gentle roof pieces to create these
upward corners that you see on Asian
architecture so the ones that I just
built and I basically just ripped this
roof building method straight from his
build it's just I think the best way to
build convincing Asian roofs and by that
I mean the roofs that curve upwards
toward the end because of course not all
Japanese buildings do this but the
bigger fancier ones like samples usually
do and I think this is really the best
way to build this kind of roof structure
now the rest of the Japanese nests of
this building I would say really hinges
on the fact that it's once again
entirely off grid so all of the walls
are on a half grid which makes it a bit
more difficult to somehow work the paths
into it because you have to work with
these cubes to shape the walls of the
grid while also you know allowing the
paths to not run into anything but I
think it worked out in the end another
struggle is making fences and horizontal
beams because even though the wooden
pillars can be placed in any placement
that you want that's not really a
struggle
there aren't any horizontal beams that
you can put you know in off-grid
positions so I ended up using actually
some letters as horizontal wooden beams
as you may know in parca texts you can
create custom text signs by typing
something and then it appears in a 3d
form in the game and I say 3d but it's
actually a bunch of overlapped alpha
textures that look 3d it's convincing
enough but it's really cool you can type
basically anything and it will turn into
a 3d sign in the game
I just typed out a long string of what's
that an underscore and it just basically
created a giant horizontal beam that I
used for the fence of the station so
that's how I somehow managed to get some
horizontal beams in there and then for
the gate in front of that I'm using a
very similar roof only on a much smaller
scale and this time for the horizontal
wooden beams I'm just using the simple
cube method of creating a point thirteen
size cube and then setting the grid to
eight so you have a tiny grid and then
connecting all of these little cubes to
make a horizontal beam and while
honestly this is a pretty good method
for making horizontal beams or really
any kind of structure in any direction
that you want to it's it's something
that's kind of resource heavy kind of
expensive and kind of a hassle to build
so I think for the station building
itself the the letters the underscores
work fine as defenses but for the gates
a much smaller structure where I wanted
to have a much more heavy texture of
wood around it
I think the cube method works a bit
better so that's it for the general
temple like structure of the station I
would say of course the path underneath
the the big gates in front is going to
be the entrance to the Q I am so good at
making terrible queues where it's really
hard to notice the queue or where they
don't really stand out too much but I
think in that sort of history this is
probably one of my better q entrances
because it's actually very noticeable
and it's also very front and center from
a gameplay perspective it should
hopefully work out quite well as well
because all of the guests coming into
the park will pass by these gates and
will think hmmm maybe I want to write
that coaster and then I'm it's just my
tasks to make that coaster fairly
expensive and hopefully attracts a lot
of guests and make some decent money now
to finish the main street's
ish area here I wanted to build some
small residential houses it's nothing
too exciting this building in particular
you actually can't enter because I
wanted to really make it look convincing
ly like a small Japanese house so it has
that porch area up front and then a very
simple gable roof on top of that I'm not
really going as much into detail as I
did with the temple but with the overall
structure of the building I'm still
trying to you know make it look as
convincingly Japanese as possible which
to be honest is very easy to do I think
Japanese architecture in particular
tends to be overdone when people are
doing it in games like this because you
very often just refer to these curved
windows and overly detailed temple like
structures but if you go to the average
house or warehouse or just inner city
building the traditional architectural
styles are really not that detailed and
sometimes really not even that different
from architectural styles in Europe for
instance when it comes to the woodwork
and things like this so honestly with
very simple pieces and with not that
many pieces but just in the right
composition I think you can really make
some very convincing Japanese buildings
as well sometimes it doesn't really have
to be too complicated now this building
next to the house is inspired by the
warehouses that you'll find particularly
there's this town called Karma GUI in in
Tokyo well technically the metropolitan
area of Tokyo but it's not actually in
the city of Tokyo but yeah pretty much
that area which has a bunch of these old
warehouses and that's what this building
was inspired by it's also a very simple
setup they're pretty much always shaped
like this they just have different
colors and different details but it's a
very very standard distinct building
style I would say and this is also going
to be the one building that's actually
gonna be functional when I was building
this I was planning to make this the
food courts but then I checked out the
these the stalls section and I realized
that there's not even a food stall
there's not even a drink store that is
already you know that you start out with
scenario with so that is kind of
difficult because that means I'm gonna
have to research stuff and then put it
in that building so for now the building
is gonna be empty except for a small
umbrella shop I believe but hopefully at
some point in the future I will have the
food shops unlocked so that I can
actually
turn this into a food court because you
have the trouble with these kind of
scenarios where you start out with a
lack of food stalls is that people do
get very upset about this and you're
also missing out a potential source of
potentional what you're missing out a
potential source of revenue as well so
it's always kind of annoying but it's
more of just a small upfront challenge
that over the long-run of the scenario
as long as you pay attention to it
shouldn't be too much of an issue
another thing that's actually research
related is that when you start out this
scenario you don't have the scenery
pieces that I'm using right now
specifically I restarted the scenario a
bunch of times and started researching
stuff because I wanted to have the
medieval structures scenery back because
the medieval structures has these roof
pieces that I'm using for the Asian
roofs all over the place and I've seen
some people complain that this scenario
misses some scenery items which to be
fair most scenarios start out with a
very limited selection of scenery and in
this one in particular if you want to go
all out on scenery you're gonna have to
research the scenery as well and that's
something that I often forget to talk
about in my videos but it's it really
has some potential and if you're trying
to play these scenarios based not just
on gameplay but also trying to make a
nice park out of it like I am then
definitely research comes into question
as well I know it's always been one of
those things that people would turn off
in rollerCoaster Tycoon for instance but
it can really be very important and
especially in this case since I needed
those medieval pieces to make the the
the whole pier Shanno roof structure
work I really had to research that
before I started the rest of the
scenario so anyway my last little build
before I try to make this park run
because I'm quickly running out of money
is going to be this wave swing next to
the lake I don't know why these things
just work out so well next to a body of
water but they're just super picturesque
so I figured if I'm gonna place this
thing anywhere it's definitely gonna be
next to Lake
and Here I am again trying to make this
complicated roof structure work but
every time it just doesn't quite work
for my tastes it's just a bit too
over-the-top I prefer my belts to be
more clean as opposed to just putting a
bunch of random details on stuff so I'm
just gonna refer it back to a much more
a simple roof style at this point and
just leave it at that also helps that
things are not sticking out because at
first I was already building a roof
where the people on the wave swing would
actually crashed through the roof so
that was some very unfortunate planning
but at least this one is a safe distance
away from the wave swinger as well so
yeah I'm not sure what I'm gonna do with
the rest of that path but I just wanted
to put this wave swing in here and then
see where I could go from there and
before I move on I'm just placing down
this carousel here to try and make some
extra money and see if I can somehow run
this park with the profits I want to say
that this isn't what it looks like but
yeah it kind of is what it looks like
I'm not making a profits it's not going
to well people don't really like the
park either
and I think the majority of issues
really just stems from the fact that
there isn't anything that's intense
enough for the people on this park
because even though they don't like very
intense rides they definitely want
something more intense than what I have
and that's gonna be difficult actually
right now let's quickly fix up that
bench because it's annoying me but yeah
basically this means that even though I
took out a loan I am still not making
money and I was actually making a very
very small profit for a tiny amount of
time but not anymore actually if I check
out the graph then you can see that my
balance was going up for a while but now
I don't really run a profits or brandy
in the park anymore so it's it's a
downward spiral so actually I'm gonna
I'm gonna pause the game here and not
let the let this disaster continue any
further my current plan is I just
researched the wooden coaster so I want
to build a woody it's gonna be intense
enough to keep the the more intense
seeking guests happy and at this point I
am
really praying that the cumulative
effects of getting more people into the
park also means that more people are
gonna write the rights that I already
have so hopefully exponentially I'm
gonna make a profit again I'm really not
sure and it's gonna be super risky
because I already took out a decently
sized loan of eight thousand dollars so
I'm gonna take out another loan and I
think it's just gonna be the eleven
thousand dollar one which means I'm
gonna have to pay a monthly fee of a few
hundred dollars in hopes of even somehow
running a profit but I'm carefully
optimistic about it either way it's the
only way that I'm gonna be able to save
this park because as it looks right now
this thing is not really doing too well
so yeah I'm sorry that I'm not gonna do
too much of a tour of the park right now
this is just a quick financial update
I'm gonna try to keep this thing afloat
but it's not gonna be very easy but uh
let's build a woody and see how it goes
[Music]
you know what forget about it I tried
for a couple of hours yesterday to
somehow make that park work but the
wooden coaster that I built just didn't
bring in the money and whatever I tried
to save it I kept going bankrupt so what
I ended up doing is perhaps the greatest
shame in all of my park attacks play
through but yeah I decided to sort of do
that thing that some people do in
rollercoaster tycoon and religious built
layouts based on how much money you can
make off of it so this is a little bit
of a Marcel voz ish kind of approach to
park attacks I built two shuttle loops
and a terrible horrible wooden coaster
on its place and it really hurts to
delete that old wooden coaster built
because the layout was just perfectly
fitting into this area but I saved it as
a blueprints hopefully I can bring it
back later but for now this stuff has
been able to make this Park run a
Prophet's and I've been able to you know
run it for a while and get some money to
finance the crazy plans that I have
because I still have some insane scenery
plans so from this point onward I'm
gonna try to
my way into a very thematic fitting
Sakura gardens eventually I'm gonna
remove these coasters and replace them
with the old GCI wooden coaster that I
made in the same location that should
really be here but hey I have some
financial investors to also make happy
either way I'm gonna focus my efforts on
a different area for now I got the idea
to build a Japanese castle on top of
this hill because I think it'll fit
perfectly here and then I'll see
whatever I can do next to that and once
I have enough money actually I probably
have a rep and enough money at this
point anyway but once I feel confidence
to tackle it I'm gonna go back into this
area and rebuild the wooden coaster that
I built earlier so yeah it's a this is
not the best situation but at least it's
something that I can go forward from
again and all I really wanted to do is
to save the Main Street which I built
here so even if I'm resorting to some
really terrible strategies here I just
wanted to make sure that I would save
these buildings and that's at least a
success so there's something good in
this let's keep going from here though
alright so the first thing I wanted to
do is clear some land at the back of
this scene that I'd built here now this
was a little bit annoying because I
forgot at this point that I made the
scenery which is already in this
scenario most notably just that bridge
with the area directly around it is all
protected so you're not allowed to
remove that or anything which is a bit
unfortunate because at first I was
figuring that I could just build the
castle right on top of that but that
wasn't gonna work
so I decided to build this castle just
next to it and it's going to be a
Japanese castle because I figured that
would be a really cool thing to add at
this point it is completely just scenery
there's not gonna be any ride or
anything in or around it honestly I've
just always wanted to try building a
Japanese car so in Park attacks and this
just seemed like the best excuse to do
so it is completely pointless otherwise
but at this point I was making so much
Bank that I figured I'm just gonna spend
all of this money anyway and see
I can build because these things are
just so much fun to build they're not
even that hard to build I think in Park
effects specifically I think the
struggle is trying to make it seem
off-grid and making every floor a little
bit
you know it's smaller than the one
underneath it because the way that these
Japanese castles are built is that
they're often just different floors
stacked upon each other where every
consecutive floor becomes a bit smaller
until the top floor is just this tiny
pavilion on top of the whole structure
and then you can add all kinds of
details on different floors different
Gables and things like this so there's a
lot of space for experimentation and
just general messing about
so it's something really fun to build I
know I've built one pretty much in
planet coaster and kind of in Planet 2
as well so haven't done that in park
attack yet so here it goes I suppose I
also have to say that once again the the
whole strategy of PHN Oh to build these
small roofs with the corners outward to
create these kind of curved Asian roofs
is such an amazing trick then I just
keep using throughout this whole park so
even if all of the roofs are gonna look
pretty much the same they're honestly
all just using his technique because I
think it's the best-looking way that you
can create Asian roofs I did have to
come up with a sort of alternative
strategy here because some of the roofs
had to be you know another half tile
back so for this I ended up making these
diagonal borders using tiny cubes and
putting them on an 8 grid diagonal path
which is a bit if you're looking you can
definitely tell that they're made out of
a bunch of cubes but if you don't really
pay too much attention to it and you're
just looking from a fair distance
I think it's convincing enough and you
really get that sort of almost PI like
structure or a bunch of cakes stacked on
top of each other with all kinds of
detail on it and this is also for me
honestly the kind of building where you
could just you know create a general
layout and then turn off your mind and
just randomly dito it everywhere and see
where it goes this is just one of these
types of structures that I think you can
really doodle or at least personally I
can we
is it just really feels like that just
doing things here and there without
having too much of a plan and just
seeing where it ends up now just this
building alone was never gonna cut it
because these castles always have some
buildings attached to them and in this
instance I was also specifically basing
this off of an image of a miniature
model of a castle that I found somewhere
which also had this smaller building
next to it so I figured I had to do
something similar and at least make this
a bit bigger
not to mention create some sort of small
open plaza between these buildings so
there's also an open space within the
castle grounds so I'm not entirely sure
what you know that the different uses of
these buildings would be but for the
overall structure and I figured it would
be best to add this small building on
the side of it as well now these
structures in real life are usually
quite old although sometimes I believe
they're also kind of imitations because
the castle in Osaka for instance is just
a modern building that was reconstructed
after an old castle but it's really just
made out of concrete and steel and even
has an elevator inside of it so whether
this building is real or not given the
context of this theme park I'm honestly
not sure I don't really you know want to
come up with too much of a lore but to
be honest they could very well just be a
modern building just a fake castle more
or less to make this scene because I
don't think this theme park would have
necessarily had to you know develop
alongside an actual real old castle
because then it probably would have been
protected anyway but yeah that pretty
much finishes off the castle itself I
decided to have a pretty wide path with
some stairs in front of it leading into
the castle grounds and then as simple
wooden gates and it's really quite
simple honestly I'm not detailing it too
much but I just think that you know all
of the different pieces the textures and
the colors work quite well together not
to mention that I accidentally also
researched the adventure theme but I'm
super happy that I did because the the
stone from the adventure pyramids is
perfect for cases like this because
foundations of Japanese castles are
often made out of some kind of rough
cobblestone and this this adventure
texture is just perfect for that at
first I was thinking that I could build
it out of fences but they don't really
simulate the way that these these stone
walls in real life often fan how its
diagonally and become wider toward the
base of the wall so that's something
that the adventurer temple theme pieces
do really well and after this well I was
looking at a flat ride and it didn't had
a it didn't have a roof on top of it so
my instincts started kicking in at this
point and I decided to add a small roof
on top of the carousel but again trying
to experiment it a bit so I also got the
fantasy theme which I believe this
curved roof is from and it's a roof that
you don't have in a lot of scenarios
it's something that you often just have
to research because it's one of those
niche pieces that you typically don't
really use it's supposed to be used in
some sort of fantasy setting but I think
it works really well as an Asian roof
now you always have to watch out with it
because there's really only one piece of
this you only get that one curved roof
piece there are no corner pieces or
smaller pieces or more gentle pieces
this is all you get so it's only useful
in a few niche cases but I think this
was a good case to use it get some
curved roof in there and it just looks
Asian enough the only thing that is a
bit annoying about this build but I
decided to not really care about it it's
the fact that people are gonna walk
through the pillars basically all the
time because there are pillars in the
middle of the flat right section but
even though I normally try to stay you
know keep clear of the the actual parts
of the flat ride this time I figured it
would look weird to have pillars at the
outside of this roof so I'm going for
aesthetics over function for this one I
suppose
and at this point I sort of did have a
technique for putting buildings off grid
otherwise which is basically using those
point five cubes to create half grid
walls and it just kind of works really
well I always avoided building too many
you know off grid buildings because I
figured it would be really difficult the
first time that I really tried doing it
I think was in pagoda Valley but at this
point with this cube method I'm kind of
confident enough that you can use it in
any situation because if you are
building a building where you want
people to go inside of it or you're
trying to house a flat right all you
have to do is just put these point five
cubes around that structure and then you
can still build an off-grid building
while having the the on grid flat ride
or a coaster or path work go into it so
honestly it just works out really well
and even though I would still love to
see it being possible to put walls on a
full grid I also kind of understand why
walls and roofs are limited or mean no I
I would love to see what's being you
know put on a half grid but I kind of
understand why they're limited to a full
grid because that just makes everything
a lot easier especially if you're new to
the game and at the end of the day if
you really want to build off grid
buildings or anything really we have all
of these basic shapes that you can
basically place in any way that you want
so that ends up working out usually now
this is going to be probably my favorite
part in this video and honestly maybe I
should just say it outright
I think this wooden coaster is probably
my favorite coaster that I've made in
the scenario playthrough so far and I
know these are some pretty big words but
for me it just hit the right balance
between the layouts working out well and
the scenery fitting the map and fitting
the coaster as well and just all
together it's quite compact while also
using the terrain it just kind of takes
all of the boxes for me and I wish there
was something about it that I could
replicate
in my next coasters but honestly it's
just I think a case where everything
just happens to work out in some way and
you're just lucky to get into the flow
and build something that you're really
happy with because if creativity is
really you know unpredictable like that
but yeah I think this coaster turned out
really cool so as you can see I deleted
my moneymakers because they'd pretty
much done what I needed them to do I had
$40,000 in the bank and figured I could
just build the park using all of this
money and put back the woody that I had
in here before it did take a bit of
shuffling around and I'm not sure if
it's exactly in the same location as it
used to be but I don't think that
matters too much what matters is that we
have the layouts and that I can continue
with my plans as I make them and at this
point I'm kind of just recreating this
station that I originally had although
with some slight differences trying to
improve it a little bit I always think
that you know the good thing about
losing progress is that whenever you do
something again you always end up doing
it better than the first time because
you've you know learned from the
mistakes that you've made the first time
and not to mention that you usually do
it faster than the first time as well
because you don't have to work out
everything anymore so when it comes to
games like this it's always annoying to
lose a save file but it's not the end of
the world because usually it's a great
opportunity to you know improve on what
you had before and I think this is
definitely a case like that as well now
I was considering putting the queue
where I had it before so my old plan was
to have the queue just go right next to
the station building and just leave it
at that but then I figured that you know
in parka tech terms that might work
because it's a long enough queue to
still queue up enough people for the
next train this coaster is gonna have a
to train operation so it's gonna be
super efficient anyway so I don't really
have to worry about capacity or anything
so I think that would have been fine but
at this point I realized that it would
be kind of boring and you wouldn't have
as much interaction between the path
work and the the coaster itself so I
decided to make this queue quite long
and a bit more realistic if you will and
have it
underneath the structure of the wooden
coaster and have a bit of interaction
with it as well so I created this small
Valley where the coaster dips underneath
the track or underneath the path and I
decided to add a bridge on top of this
it's a bit difficult to make an
asian-looking bridge in parking tanks
because at this point the pieces are
getting so small that you know the
difference is it's hard to really add
Asian details so you have to rely on
shapes of buildings and this bridge is
just too small to really differentiate
it but I think it works out with these
sort of very lights eaves and yeah I
think just in general the fact that it
uses the same type of objects and the
same colours as a lot of the buildings
in the scenario just make it fit in in
the context so even though the bridge on
its own wouldn't really look too
typically Asian I'm gonna try to at
least you know have the theming around
it reflect that and at that point I
think it should work out fine now at
this point I got to work on the station
which is a bit annoying because it's
gonna be a huge station mostly because I
have that station fly by this woody is
modeled after GCI wooden coasters even
though it has a drop which goes straight
down which is a bit unusual for a DCI
coaster although not unseen because it
definitely exists but yeah these kinds
of coasters typically have a station
flyby we're halfway through the layouts
the coaster just enters the station
building usually it's above the height
of the station so you can actually see
the cars passing by when you're in the
station but sometimes it just goes
underneath it as well whatever it really
wants to do I guess but the cool thing
about it is that you you know as as
somebody riding the coaster you have
this amazing sort of head chopper moment
where you're going at full speed into a
building and that's just really cool in
general but if you're standing in the
station whenever those trains pass
through the building it just creates
this super loud Rumble which is really
awesome it never really feels to hype me
up for a coaster although I also have to
say it totally hurts my eardrums
well usually those things are loud as
heck but yeah it's it's really cool and
it's a very typical elements that you
see in GCI coasters so I had to put that
in here it just means that the roof has
to be quite tall to actually fit all of
that now for this roof structure I'm
again using sort of a temple like
structure where it's quite fat in the
middle there and then we have two wings
coming out from the sides this kind of
architecture just works out really well
for station buildings I've realized
Japanese temples kind of just have
shapes that work out for station
buildings which you can't really say for
any other or most other vernacular
architectural types around the world I
guess it's not so easy to you know make
an Alpine style station because you
usually end up with a building that
looks like it's stretched out bigger
than it should be or more open than it
should be but because in real life these
buildings are always quite large on a
rectangular sort of footprints and very
open with lots of pillars they actually
just kind of work out really well as a
coaster station I think I cut out some
footage there where I was placing the
gates for the entrance of the queue
because it's basically a copy of the
gates that you see at the front of the
park I just decided to remove the sort
of wooden walkway that's on top of it
and just change the detailing but the
overall shape and the roof structure is
basically the same I'm also trying to
fit these in a little bit together so
while you may have noticed that for
every building I build I try to give it
a slightly different roof color so all
the roofs are basically dark gray but
some are more reddish gray and so a more
blue or greenish gray but for these two
buildings just to make sure that the
station building and the gates of the
queue entrance look like they belong
together I decided to just go for the
exact same color but usually I just you
know have some minor differences in
colors for some variety
and all of the foliage even here I
decided would probably be best to just
have it be inspired by Japanese garden
foliage so that means lots of round
bubbly trees and sinking lots of trees
into the ground to create these around
large shrubs and a few pine trees
between that as well and just all
together I think that works out as a as
a Japanese looking enough kind of
structure I decided to add a little bit
of support here to the wooden coaster
but I didn't have to add too much
because at the end of the day it's a
very terrain conforming coaster so most
of it has very little supports but it's
this kind of thing that I tend to forget
so hence why I'm only doing it at this
stage in building the coaster because
only at this point I kind of realized
wait I should probably add some extra
lateral supports and yeah that basically
more or less finishes the coaster itself
only thing I still added is a bit more
detail on the cue line I believe and
just this area in general creating a
quick stone fence using also the and the
adventurer borders which turned out to
become so useful throughout these builds
I didn't really realize that this makes
such a good stone fence it was kind of a
accidental discovery but yeah it kind of
works out really well all I really put
between that are some 1 meter pillar
pieces but that's all these borders from
The Adventure theme are just really good
for whenever you need you know it
straights stone piece because it just
kind of resembles that for some reason
but yeah that is basically it for the
wooden coaster I'm gonna move over to a
different section because I don't think
there's much to add there anymore at
this point I let the game run for a bit
and see if I could still make a bit of
profit and I could very quickly see my
profit swindling so I realized that I'm
gonna have to build some stuff and
quickly lest I not just lose all of my
money so what I ended up building here
is a looping coaster and it's always
kind of difficult to you know identify
what these things are exactly because in
the game
they're kind of a cross between an arrow
corkscrew and a swatch Cup blooper but
in this case I decided to make the
layouts as if it were an arrow corkscrew
coaster so double loop double corkscrew
is what I wanted to get in here and
anything else in the layout is just
going to be some curves and Hills to get
to different places but it's just a very
standard fare layouts now you might
already be thinking that you know what's
going on with this this scenario asks
you to build lower intensity rides and
to be completely honest I think the
scenario is being way too hard on saying
that you need lower intensity rides
because in park attacks it's kind of
difficult to build real high intensity
rides because even most writes that in
real life would be considered thrilling
end up getting a medium intensity here
in the game which people in this park
are still willing to ride you really
have to put a lot of effort into making
a high intensity ride either that or
make a ride that just you know has an
unrealistic layout with way too many
lateral G's or positive or any other
kind of g-forces but so long as you have
an idea of what a coaster is
realistically like and can build a
smooth layout with a decent speed you're
probably going to get a medium intensity
rating so I wasn't really too concerned
with making this coaster too intense
because I figured that the guests in the
park were probably going to want to ride
it really the goal here was to create an
as high as possible
excitement rating while keeping the
intensity rating in the medium so people
wouldn't skip it and I ended up
succeeding in that I'm not exactly sure
what the stats on these things are but
all of the coasters in this build have
pretty much the stats that I was looking
for with a medium excitement rating or
in a medium intensity rating in a really
high excitement rating so I think that
whole sort of lower intensity statistics
thing that was promised at the beginning
of the scenario is just much less of a
concern then I figured it would be
before hand which to be fair is also the
thing that I've generally
red based on reviews and other people's
experiences with this scenario it's
easier in a sense that you know the you
don't really have to pay too much
intention to making your rice less
intense the real thing that makes this
scenario so difficult is the fact that
you don't have very easy rights to play
with it's hard to attract people into
the scenario into the park I should say
and just overall reaching the goals of
this scenario and turn out to be a lot
more difficult then I figured it would
be but more about that later so what I
actually wanted to do with this ride and
the very reason that I built a steel
coaster here in the first place is the
fact that Park attacks has dragon cars
which is a bit unusual I'm not even
entirely sure why these are in the game
because they're not something that you
really see in real life also the zero
car in front of the train which has the
dragon head on it is absolutely huge
it's such a long boy that I'm not even
sure if it could realistically traverse
the track because there are some pretty
tight turns and inversions on this
layouts and the first car is just super
long so it doesn't look too flexible but
it's a super cool looking train it's
something in parks tech that I've never
ever used before because I've never
really felt like it fits into the theme
of what I'm building but now that I've
got an Asian build going the Japanese
love that dragons I decided there was
finally time to bring out the dragon
cars and just create a dragon-type steel
coaster I always got confused which of
the coaster types in this game had the
dragon cars for a while I thought it was
the junior coaster or the powered
coaster but now it turns out that it's
really the steel coaster all along so
yeah that's where we're going with this
and the station again it's just this off
grid half grid kind of building made out
of cubes using the same kind of roofs
that I've been using throughout this
build although at this point I had a
small epiphany and ended up switching
out the regular windows for one of the
detail pieces from the adventure theme
which makes a really cool small wooden
window so
kind of gonna miss that piece in any
scenario where we don't have the
adventure thing because it's super
useful the adventure theme in general is
super cool I also decided that at this
point even though the guests are not
actually going to use this because they
can't really use anything that's not
path I wanted to add some stepping
stones on the lake because that's just
something that you often find in
Japanese gardens realistically you know
you would see very flat large rocks as
stepping stones as opposed to these
perfectly round things although you do
see that as well sometimes but given the
restrictions of this game I tried using
some flat rock flat rocks at some point
but it just doesn't look as good as just
using a few grey cylinders and making it
look like some round rock work pieces
and yeah other than that I'm just
creating a small pond at the back of the
station for the cue line to go around
it's pretty simple cue line but I still
like decorating my cue lines a bit as if
it were a real life theme park even
though in park stacks you don't really
need long cue lines like that because
probably you're not gonna have that many
people queuing up anyway Plus this
coaster again does have a block break
section at the end which means I can use
two trains so we've got some to train
ops going so it's probably not going to
have to struggle when it comes to
capacity but it's still something that I
want to consider moving on from that I
decided to do a bit of custom scenery
here make some custom supports out of
pipe pieces for the loops and as you
might notice I make the inversions on
this coaster yellow I don't really have
a particular reason for it other than it
just kind of looks cool and you can
recolor track pieces and I thought the
coaster looked a bit boring being
entirely purple I thought it blended a
bit too much into the environments and
giving inversions a different colour is
just I think that's that's a leftover
from rollercoaster tycoon
it has to be it's not something that you
really see in real life but it's
something that I really like doing
because I think I just did it a lot in
rollercoaster tycoon but yeah it just
works out pretty well I think I can't
really add too much to the
supports of the loop so they are just
going to be vertical
you know black beams that's gonna be
it's there are some other pipe pieces in
the game but then none of them are
really shaped like actual coaster
supports but honestly this is better
than nothing so I decided to just add
this which unfortunately in the game if
you don't custom support them loops are
unsupported so it's also something that
I always tried to custom support
whenever it comes up because otherwise
it just ends up looking a bit
unrealistic now at this point I wasn't
really confident that I was gonna reach
the guests goals of this scenario so
even though I'm honestly really happy
with what the park looks like at this
point the things that I'm building from
now on are just going to be to reach the
goals so first off I wanted to build a
jumper flat ride because this thing
should hopefully just bring in the
guests I figured it would be cool to
have the cue line go around it with a
small Asian roof structure on top of it
and have it sort of look toward the
section where you have the component
coaster interacting with the two
corkscrews of the looping coaster and in
addition to that just adding some
general scenery to this area to make it
look a bit fancier also one small thing
that I did is add a staff room in here
because my staff was complaining about a
lack of staff rooms at first so I ended
up putting one next to the entrance but
that was never supposed to be a staff
room building that I didn't really plan
for it I just had to put that there as
an emergency so I figured this would be
a good place to put a staff room now
I'm gonna finish that in a second but in
the meantime I want to move over to a
different part in the park where I went
to build what are these things call
again a wipeouts there we go
just because well I always kept this
space reserved for a flat ride just in
case I needed one at the end which if
you look down at my guest count at the
bottom left you can tell I'm getting
close to 500 but I'm not quite there and
after running the game for a while and
even trying to massively campaign my
park I still wasn't getting there so I
figured all right
I'm gonna have to break open this space
that I camp reserved for another flat
ride I was honestly fine keeping this
place empty as well because it was like
a nice relaxing garden parts of the park
but I'm really gonna have to add this
thing in here that said I'm not gonna
put a roof on top of this thing because
I think it doesn't really work too well
just a little bit of scenery on top of
the entrance and just in general around
this build so if we skip forward a
little bit you can see basically what it
looks like at the end I did have a small
building on the side of it as well but
ended up removing that's just because
yeah I thought it wasn't really looking
too good there and the final thing that
I'm adding at least I think this is my
very last thing is a food court next to
the jumper because I still wasn't
getting to my guests goal after running
the game for a bit my ratings never
really went above 60% which is quite bad
and after checking the the guests and
what they thought of the park I figured
that it had to do with the fact that
they couldn't get enough food and drinks
and also toilets so I did sneak a toilet
in somewhere actually that's in the
station building at the steel coaster
but yeah I'm basically adding this
building to fulfil their needs and
hopefully make them happy enough to keep
coming to the park because otherwise
without you know these kind of
facilities before very quickly leaving
the park so regardless of my very heavy
advertising you know I had a I had a
pretty decent influx but also people
kept leaving so hopefully this is gonna
keep them in and I can finish the
scenario so let's see how it's doing how
should I put this this isn't what it
looks like no actually this is exactly
what it looks like I wasn't able to get
to 500 people consistently for two
months for a long time so after a lot of
thinking about my myself about my life
counting my life choices recounting the
things that I've done wrong in my life
the the sins that I've committed
everything that will stack
once I'm at the gates of hell or heaven
wherever I end up looking at all of this
evidence I figured okay there's this one
one more thing probably won't hurt I'll
just remove this path in front of the
entrance because I'm really not gonna
make this you know if I don't do this so
yeah this is this is what it took I feel
like I've gone back to roller coaster
tycoon at this point because it's such
an old roller coaster tycoon strategy
but I hitting 500 people in the park
wasn't too difficult but keeping them in
for two months was just nearly
impossible because every single time I
would lose it just before the end of the
two months so I'm sorry I'm returning to
my roller coaster tycoon days to be fair
there was actually a time where I put a
sign in front of this with no entry for
guests which is the roller coaster
tycoon 3 strategy or roller coaster
Kuman strategy in general but it didn't
work which was kind of funny so I think
that the devs came up with a way to
counter this which is very smart I'll
give them that but I'm smarter so I just
ended up removing the path in front of
the entrance it's horrible I feel bad
about it it's it's a terrible thing it
kind of feels like a cheesed my way
through the scenario but I have to be
completely honest the way that I built
this park I just filled in every space
that I wanted to fill in and I'm very
scenery focused so the only other way
that I could finish the scenario was to
shoehorn in a flat ride somewhere but
for my personal feelings it would kind
of ruin the flow of the park that I have
right now so I just ended up going to
this now let's just end this video on a
more positive note and do some POVs of
some of the coasters so here's the
junior coaster it's actually quite
popular I've never seen a full train on
this thing before but judging by the
queue it's very crowded here this thing
only runs once rain because it is a
kiddie coaster at the end of the day but
I might have also added some block
brakes at the end there because it
really could use two trains looking at
this
but yeah you know what these things are
like it's a very standard layouts just
some hills and curves kind of following
the terrain a little bit but I think it
works out quite well in this context now
moving on of course we have the
waterfront here with the swinging the
the chair swing and also this stone
fence which I think just works out so
well I'm kind of kicking myself for not
using this more because I think it would
work really well in a Japanese garden
setting but even just for this small
waterfront I think it's a nice touch and
then of course we have the wooden
coaster here I never actually named my
coasters which I kind of feel like I
should do but really all I care about is
decoration and scenery in this kind of
game and even when I come up with names
they tend to be sort of generic ones
that I just come up with in in the
moment so it's not something that I pay
too much attention to I really just want
to focus on the scenery in general so
it's a straight drop which is kind of
unusual for a DCI but after that we get
into some more standard gzi affair some
overbank turns little air time pops
although I also have to say that the
pops aren't quite as snappy as they
would be in real life just because of
the way that architect works but overall
I tried to make this layout feel like oh
cool interaction right there I tried to
make the layout feel like it has a GC I
like shape to it including of course the
station flyby over here and also there
is a doubled down over there and finally
we're finishing this layouts with a
quick dip here I actually really like
this curve this is kind of GC I asked
and it's something that you can quite
easily do in Park attacks all you really
have to do is you're at a straight
section and you're banked and what I
like to do is then just make another
straight piece than a tiny curve and
then go flats so that you have a flat
section here and then a flat section
here and you can just have Auto connects
connect a curve between that so we have
one curve that starts going down and
then flattens out
again which is a really cool effect and
you can use it in a pinch and also just
for the way that it looks because it
just gives so many more options to when
it comes to making layouts in this game
and then of course there is the coaster
that I did give a name
tatsumaki just because it's dragon in
Japanese I mean the dragon cars are kind
of a meme with a big zero car but I
think it fits into the park quite well
especially with these kind of
highlighted inversions here and of
course we have some cool interaction
with the path a fly by going over the
station here and then in the back half
of this ride flying through these
corkscrews and with a quick turnaround
we get back into the break run very
simple layouts but I think given the
context of the park it works out quite
well and I'm actually quite happy with
how this station turned out even if at
this point these buildings are starting
to look like each other quite a bit this
is definitely one of my favorite
buildings in this scenario and I think
it works out just right in this location
and yeah I guess that is pretty much it
for the major rides in this park of
course I have a few flat rides here and
there and an extra food courts also a
staff room in this little building and
then there's just a building which is
completely decoration for actually what
I should do is open this up to the
public because I had this closed for a
while because people were going here and
becoming tired and then leaving the park
which was quite a hindrance to me trying
to get 500 guests into the park but now
that I reached the goal I feel pretty
safe removing them as well it was just a
bit annoying sometimes having lots of
people walk around here get tired not
really write anything and then want to
go home I think in this game it's really
detrimental if you have a very spread
out layout of a park and there are large
areas without any rides which in this
scenario is kind of hard to avoid
because you start off with a fairly
large map with a lot of paths work and I
sort of started building all over the
member right
GetGo but it's something to keep in mind
anyway alright now that's pretty much it
for circular Gardens I'm just gonna save
this thing one last time and what's
actually kind of funny is if you scroll
through this you see all of the tries
that I have to save and this is this is
what it took to finally get to my
finished succulent Gardens also a fun
little note you might have seen silica
slopes for a second there I don't want
to spoil too much but I recorded this
episode and silica slopes out of
chronological order so silica slopes is
gonna follow this video but I did record
it already it's a bit of a strange
confusing situation it's just because
silica slopes is on my laptop and I
worked on this on my computer at the
same time but it's team synched so I do
have both of these files anyway let's
let's go back to the main camp campaign
menu and see which scenario icons
because to be honest I actually have no
idea all right so we get the station no
way the delivery's building which
compared to some of the buildings which
i've made in this scenario is lacking
some detail i guess and the new scenario
is going to be disaster Peaks overlord
okay that's gonna be a fun one looking
forward to trying that it's honestly a
very interesting scenario but next video
will be about silica slopes and I can
already tell you this is going to be a
really interesting video ok I think I
came up with some cool layouts for the
coasters primarily but you guys are
gonna see that next time until then see
you